Yeah,
I think Eddie artist's responsibility is
first and foremost to create good art
and I think hip hop.
I'm certainly not the first to say this,
probably not the first to say this on
big thing,
but hip hop has always been held to
standards that I thought were
unrealistic and unfair and standards
that no other modern pop music forum has
been held to as far as the our lyrical
contents and how much we deliver a
substantive message or whether we craft
our music into a comprehensive handbook
for how to live your life.
I mean,
I don't think anyone has ever looked at
blues or jazz or country or any other
form.
No one has ever looked at John Coltrane
and said he's failing as an artist
because he didn't provide a detailed
blueprint for political change in our
country or a detailed blueprint for how
to raise your children.
You know,
because people recognize that the value
of John Coltrane's music comes in its
musical expressiveness.
But with hip hop,
a lot of people don't recognize hip
hop's musical value.
So they latch onto what's easier for
them to understand.
Which is the lyrical content and judging
strictly on that basis.
So I think hip hop gets a raw deal in a
lot of ways,
especially because right when hip hop
was beginning to be discovered by the
mainstream.
It was right towards the end of what
people call a conscious era with groups
like public enemy who raised hopes very
high for having this generation fill the
void that had been left behind when the
civil rights movement ended.
Um,
the black power era had ended due to
cointelpro and self implosion and
whatever else went on.
I mean,
I think people were hoping for some kind
of voice to rise up and when you had
public enemy and all the other groups
around him speaking so compellingly,
I think people got their hopes so high
that they get really unrealistic
expectations for how much these young
musicians could really deliver.
As far as offering substantive social
and political leadership.
And I think,
I mean,
I working,
working in sort of a left wing
progressive circle of nonprofit media
has always been a struggle for me to get
people to recognize that hip hop should
be recognized for his musical value
first and foremost.
And if we're making great music,
then we did our jobs and if we're
expressing something that's explicitly
political or positive,
that's great,
but that's icing on the cake.
If you don't have the foundation of
great music underneath that,
you know,
it doesn't matter if it was all about
the message and only the message.
Cornell West would be the best rapper in
the world,
which I'm sure he would agree.
Yes.